[Musique]
le conseil départemental de l'habitat et
de l'hébergement s'est réuni ce jeudi 25
août 2016 dans l'hémicycle du Palais de
la source cette instance a réuni sous la
présidence du département tous les
acteurs du logement aidé et de
l'hébergement après l'installation de
cette instance et l'élection de son
bureau des points d'étape et perspective
ont été dressés sur différentes
thématiques mise en vre dans le domaine
de l'habitat et de
l'hébergement le cdH par son nom
l'indique c'est le conseil départemental
de l'habitat et de l'hébergement qui
c'est une instance partenariale qui
réunit l'État les services de l'État la
Région le Département les bailleurs
sociaux les communes les interco et
d'autres opérateurs et aussi des
associations qui uvrent en faveur de
l'habitat et de l'hébergement
aujourd'hui il est important pour
l'ensemble de partenaires pour servic de
l'État et la Région le Département de
remettre en place ce conseil
départemental de l'habitat et de
l'hébergement puisque la politique de
logement est un enjeu majeur un
véritable débat politique et nous sommes
c'est un c'est une politique donc au
centre de nos préoccupations alors nous
devons tous ensemble relancer comme il a
été dit la construction de logement la
réhabilitation des logements sociaux et
amplifier les interventions en mat en
matière d'amélioration it au profit des
familles les plus
[Musique]
démunies